now that's the same thing that the
the big hedge funds were doing with
gamestop right they were buying
puts on they had like billions of
dollars tied up and puts for
on gamestop is that how is that accurate
yes and no so the people that the the
funds that lost money were actually
short the stock
unlike the people that are on wall
street bets are a lot of these guys that
are using robin hood
that are just retail traders and they
have a few hundred bucks or a few
thousand bucks to throw at it hedge
funds have millions or billions of
dollars and so they don't need
there are some trade-offs when you use
stock options it's not all fun and games
you can lose a lot of money and if you
have
uh the money to buy the 100 shares
you're better off buying the hundred
shares and you are with buying the call
the call only helps you when you're
broke right and you're really just
trying to get rich
uh so the hedge funds don't need to use
that uh
the the the ones that made the headlines
they were actually short the stock so
they went there and there and they bet
the the shares would go down
uh and so those are the guys that you
see in the news but you're not entirely
wrong in that there is a third
participant that almost
nobody talks about uh which is the
participants in the options market
uh there's every time that you buy a
call somebody has to sell it to you
and every time you buy a put somebody
has to sell that to you too most of the
time the people that sell it to you are
also hedge funds and most of the time
those hedge funds that sell you those
calls or puts they don't care if the
stock goes up or down
they make money they they make let's
call it a commission
or a fee uh whenever they sell you that
that call option that pull option
and they have ways of of not caring if
the stock goes up or down
you know and they have to pay you off if
you ended up making money or whatever
they have ways to stay in what's called
that delta neutral and
uh the the the mechanics of how that
that that wave of stake that delta
neutral also
helped the entire uh movement and
momentum to push the price of the stock
up so
they don't care the ones that sell you
the ball the calls on the puts they
don't care if the stock goes up or down
the hedge funds they were straight up
short the stock they said i'm going to
short this thing
and the reason why they were short the
stock is uh
stock options have like an expiration
date so if you're not right by a certain
date
you lose all your money so so the hedge
funds have the luxury of saying well i
don't know when
gamestop is going to go down but it's
going to go down eventually so i might
as well not put an expiration date on it
do you think the purpose of making all
this [ __ ] so confusing
is just so they could manipulate it
however they [ __ ] want and make all
the money they want without getting in
trouble
it is but you know that's the beauty of
it i think that's the reason why this
thing made so much news
is because retail traders from their
cell phones were able to pull the pants
down on the complexity it can be
complicated if you want me to really
explain the nitty-gritties of it like
i'll put you to sleep but but it's as
easy as answering with that red arrow or
that green arrow from your robin hood
account like that's all that they needed
to do to realize
oh okay all you need to do is take the
opposite side of the trade you think
it's going to suck you think gamestop is
going to go out of business because of
coronavirus or whatever because they're
outdated
that's fine i believe that you're wrong
and i'm just gonna take the other side
of the trade and behind the scenes
there's all this
complex [ __ ] that nobody understands but
they don't really need to understand
and that's that's the beauty of this
they prove the fact that you don't need
to have
your certificate your cfa cert
certification or your master's in
finance or whatever you could just have
to
answer with the button with the green
one or the red one
right that's what robin hood did right
they added they made it a little bit
more transparent
for like the everyday people to be able
to play the game
but i'm i i'm talking about like
originally like the people on wall
street
they initially wanted it to be super
super complicated
by using all these crazy [ __ ] words
and terms and
and all this stuff just so normal people
wouldn't be able to understand it before
robin hood before [ __ ] like robin hood
or before the internet even
could be i mean i think that kind of
that's just i think it's effective
like i'm currently getting into crypto
and that's how i feel about that there's
they have their own lingo they have
their own kind of culture
you don't necessarily feel welcome right
away and
uh you know in the previous life i was a
volunteer firefighter and when i started
doing that stuff they had their own
culture and their own lingo and their
own ways of trying to fit in everyone
likes to have their little club
and i think that's just kind of like a
fact of life if you have
if you like a sports team for example
you know you're going to wear those
colors and you're going to know
particular stats or whatever and
it's it's it's kind of a part of
belonging to
to some community that it kind of goes
with the flow but as far as the
complexity is concerned it really isn't
what was i going to say
uh you sold the rights to the story of
the breakup between you and the guys who
are currently getting control of it too
can you tell me which studio you sold to
yeah it was rat pack
um that was it's public yeah it's a big
studio they did
hundreds of movies that are really big
so did they reach out to you like when
this whole thing like sort of blew up on
the internet
yeah you know it was actually kind of
interesting uh i started getting
contacted by all sorts of uh movie
people you know
producers and writers and directors and
and
studios and this was far outside my
my understanding the hollywood business
is completely
foreign to me and uh and so yeah so i
started kind of lobbing the calls and
everyone was super helpful that
one guy even uh wanted to try and
uh secure me so bad he bought a flight
to mexico and he was like hey i'm gonna
be there my flight lands tomorrow
morning you know i'm gonna take you out
for some drinks
and we're gonna sign this thing right
and i was like dude you should have
asked me because i'm gonna be out of
town this week
so he came down to mexico and i don't
know what he did um oh my god
but yeah no i so i ended up talking to a
lot of people a lot of big names that
you'll probably recognize
that worked on a lot of really prominent
movies a lot of people that ended up
uh signing deals of their own with movie
studios
and uh and kind of hearing out their
pitch and learning about how it works
and and
the the the most promising offer was
this one from rat pack so i just went
ahead and took it
now did those guys talk to the other
guys on the other side of the uh
on the guys who are running the reddit
thread now it is a
deep rabbit hole uh
there's so many people that are running
the reddit thread now and in fact
the people that were running the reddit
thread then were different than the ones
that are running it today and by then i
mean january or february yeah because
there continues to be drama
some of it related to the original
problem and some of it not but
essentially i was at the top and then
there was uh
and the way that reddit works is you
create a subreddit you're the top
moderator
and you basically have full control you
can add and remove every
monitor reader below you you have full
permissions and as you go adding
moderators you can give them permissions
and even if you give them full rights so
they can do whatever they want
they can't remove anyone that's above
them as a moderator so if there's ever a
disagreement whoever is further up the
food chain
is is ultimately the one that that's in
command and so the group of people that
were left there before
there was some more infighting and uh
and those guys
the best of my understanding they did
speak to movie studios uh
and i don't know if anything happened
with that i think it also had part
partly to do with the fact that they too
ended up getting removed
uh by now this third group of moderators
so it's it's kind of the wild west there
[Laughter]
i